en fi le esperan para comprar pan a
precio reducido en el distrito de su
tangas y en estambul un bastión de apoyo
del presidente de reye tayyip erdogán y
su partido acá pero incluso aquí los
residentes están perdiendo la paciencia
y el gobierno debe cambiar porque
durante 20 años ha sido el mismo sistema
la misma política
la situación es realmente mala no soy
solo yo la gente la está pasando muy mal
con panes vendidos apenas a mitad de
precio en una panadería estándar la
producción casi se ha duplicado para
satisfacer la demanda se trata de una
decisión tomada por el alcalde de
estambul como respuesta a la creciente
crisis
que estamos produciendo 1.5 millones de
panes y todavía hay colas así que no es
suficiente es una clara señal de pobreza
y la situación actual no es sólo una
crisis económica sino una crisis
política lo veo como un reflejo de la
incapacidad de dirigir el país
mientras la línea continúa cayendo en
picada miles han salido a las calles
pidiendo la dimisión de erdogán pero el
presidente que insta a la población a
confiar en él asegurando que las bajas
tasas de interés hacen bajar el costo de
vida la inflación superó el 21 por
ciento el mes pasado alcanzando un
máximo en tres años
algunos de estos precios altos volverán
a bajar pronto
desgraciadamente una de las razones del
aumento desorbitado de los precios en
nuestro país son los oportunistas
codiciosos
si bien eslogan señala que su objetivo
es la prosperidad y la estabilidad
duradera la prioridad para muchos turcos
por ahora es un cambio inmediato para
aminorar la abrumadora inflación